>>
[Piano music playing]
Loic: Hi, my name is Loic Le Meur and I'm -- I've been based
in the
Bay Area for about three years now.
As you can tell, I'm French.
I'm an interpreter.
I cannot fix my accent so I gave up fixing it.
And I'm thrilled to be here so thank you for inviting me.
I have creating a few startups in Europe and currently I'm
doing two
things probably like five stock tons.
The first is seize me which is about bringing all the social
software
that Scoble has talked about together because it's a real
pain to go
and check all those places and share in all those places so
we're
solving this very specific problem.
So we're on six platform so if you have an Android phone you
can try,
if you have a Blackberry you can try, iPhone that gets web
everywhere.
And the other thing I'm doing is a conference called "The
Web in
Paris" which gathers two and a half thousand people from 50
countries -- lots of students, too -- and it became the
largest tech
events in Europe, one of the top in the world, and we did it
with zero
marketing.
Absolutely zero marketing.
All with social software.
It started with 200 people, now we have two and a half
thousand and
every year I get people complain that I have not invited
them because
we don't invite anyone.
We don't have any salesperson calling, we don't have any
marketing
material.
Zero.
Okay?
It does like $1.5 million in revenue every year.
Lethal business.
Barely breaks even.
This is what I've been offered to talk about today is how
the
marketing is changing with social software and who in the
room would
like to launch this business in the future?
That's all?
Okay.
>>
[Laughing]
Loic: Half of a room only?
Wow.
Come on.
You can do it.
>>
[Laughing]
Loic: You know, I was at TED last week and James Cameron,
Avatar,
right, and James said, you have the right to fail but you
never have
the right to fear something it was like that.
It'll come back to me.
You shouldn't be scared of failure.
You can fail but don't fear anything.
Just try it.
So anyway, I'm going to constraint this.
This is my blog and I've -- I've written this process today
which is
how I think marketing is changing and the rules that either
startups
or anything you do should follow to some extent and even
large
businesses.
There are 22 of them and I have 15 minutes so I have to go
really
fast.
This is why I wrote it if you want to find it again.
But the first thing -- and I'm going to adapt it to
entrepreneurship
because you're interested in that -- I think the first thing
you have
to do is not market research if you want to start a
business.
Is really to identify an empty space which you think is
interesting
and just focus on that.
Someplace where not that many people have created.
So for example in location these days there is a lot
happening, like,
you know, Foursquare, and Gawala, and Google Latitude, like,
saying
where you are is something very new.
Twitter is still, even though it's two and a half years old,
a
fantastic ecosystem which has a lot of empty space.
By empty space I men a lot of spaces where you can create.
So focus on that, find a niche, make it as small as possible
so that
you can be as good as possible in that niche.
If you make it too wide, it's gonna be very risky because
you -- it's
difficult to be really good. So try to be really, really
good at
something very, very, very small.
Probably the best in the world as Seth Godin would say.
Try to be that.
And then listen.
So first rule is listen.
Just so easy today.
You use Twitter Search, you use Google Block Search, you use
-- now
Google has this realtime search and you just follow this
space and see
what people are doing and what people are saying about it.
If your brand is not on quoted twitter these days it's
either dead or
it doesn't exist yet.
I'd rather have people criticize heavily our brand than not
talk about
it at all because it's word of mouth and again these
conferences that
I take as example very often the web went from 200 people
like a bunch
of friends gathering six years ago into two and a half
thousand people
just from word of mouth.
So you'd rather have word of mouth, even negative.
We had a big crisis at the web when I invited politicians.
We had two president the same day, Shimon Peres and the
French
President Nicolas Sarkozy, speak and that created a whole,
you know,
controversy because bloggers didn't want to meet the
politicians that
much and the way I did it by imposing it and not telling
people before
I created a huge mess.
I had, like, the worst week of my life.
Only criticism, you're burnt, you're never going to be able
to govern
those people again, it's awful what you did to us, and it
actually
turned into a real huge positive for the conference because
I
answered -- actually, Scoble advised me about on that --
every single
piece of piece of criticism.
I listened to them all, I listened and answered every single
one of
them and then I said what I would do with it.
So from probably not to impose politicians anymore to an
audience that
was not prepared for that.
That was a good lesson.
You could have told me that before I'm sure; right?
Not to do that?
Answer -- as I was saying, answer, answer, answer.
It looks very easy to say it but it's not that easy to
answer.
Many brands listen but they don't engage.
Many brands, as Robert said, Scott Monty at Ford or, you
know,
various -- there is Dell for example, Richard at Dell, and
Twitter.
You can follow those brands are answering all day long.
And as I said, focus on the negative and start by this
first.
It's a mark of attention.
If people criticize you or your brand, sometimes insult you
-- very
often; right?
It's awful what you read.
That's okay.
It's attention.
It mean that is care.
So, you know, answer and get to them.
Of course you have to find a limit if it's a troll maybe you
don't
want to engage that much but -- and thank people.
If they say your brand rocks, if it's cool, just thank them.
Engage 24 hours a day.
I'm sorry.
This isn't big.
Maybe we should have done slides after all.
Anyway, engage 24 hours a day.
The way we did it is we have two full-time community
evangelists in
San Francisco and one in Europe so that we can be 24 hours a
day and
you could tell ho but we can't afford that.
If you think about it, it is the budget of a PR agency.
The monthly cost of a PR agency, you scratch that, I'm gonna
make new
friends today and cancel that, put it in full-time community
evangelists who will listen and answer all day long.
My goal is that anyone who says "Seesmic" on Twitter we
answer.
Even if it's oh, that's great.
We answer it.
That's what I want to do.
Very tough to do 24 hours a day.
I guarantee if you do that, you're going to have so much
love and
interaction.
It's about a small quantity of people engaging with your
brands and
not millions.
Every single user that you make happy by answering will tell
ten other
friends that Sees -- that your brand is cool.
That's what we do.
It worked very well for us.
That's our only market budget is word of mouth.
Be as transparent as possible -- I have to speed up.
So don't cheat.
If your product sucks, you have to recognize that it sucks.
>>
[Laughing]
Loic: If --
>>
[Laughing]
Loic: If it's not complete, that's okay.
People will forgive you for not being perfect but never
forgive you
for cheating, for saying no, no, no.
We put it under the carpet.
Like, you know, the old style advertising when you used to
say
everything is fantastic; right?
This car has no problems.
It's the best car in the world; and you never talk about the
negative.
Sometimes actually talking ant the negatives in public as
you are the
CEO of that startup or if it's your project makes it even
stronger
because you recognize that it's a problem.
So when you launch your startup, my advice is launch it as
fast as
possible, you know, throw yourself in the water and just
start
swimming.
You will learn and iterate.
Group for feedback.
I'm going to show you how we do it.
Good with feedback on a site like this which is here this
one is
yourethevoice.
So we have so much feedback.
We have a mention of Seesmic of every minute that we can't
really
tell.
It's very difficult even though that's what I like to do.
So what we do it's sort of a dig like.
If you want to see, you know, our products so for example on
Seesmicweb, our web-based version, you have our users enter
feature
suggestions and ideas and they can put whatever they like
and then
people vote on them.
So you can see for example we support twitter, whatever you
want,
facebook, one of the people wanted on that and we're
building on just
that right now; and so I call this my public road map.
Public because anyone can see it, including the competition,
so you
know, you have to be careful of course.
But say I want to see what people want on my Blackberry
product I have
that here.
All our products have. a transparent feedback forum like
this and that
has been -- that has proven very, very useful for us.
So gather feedback on a feedback site like this.
Very, very agile as you create the products.
So one way we do it when we launch my company two years ago
here, we
launched it as -- I had this dream that everybody would
start talking
in video and that didn't happen yet.
It will.
Trust me I'm sure it will.
But we were too early and we didn't have enough traction so
we changed
everything into what our company's doing now.
You have to be agile.
If it doesn't work, just change and move the space into
something that
has more traction.
So change your priorities often based on this public road
map that
I've shown you and keep moving.
You have to be very, very agile with this.
Don't forget to innovate.
Scoble said, if a Porsche -- if Porsche had listened to its
users, it
would become a Volvo because if you got a big trunk.
And so listening to the users is not enough.
You also have to innovate, create things, the empty space
that wasn't
created before, you have to create a presence on the most
popular
social software, all of them.
You have no idea -- maybe you have but I had no idea on how
many
interactions I would get different in Linkdin than on
Twitter or
facebook.
They are not the same people.
You think they are the same.
They are not the same.
I am not getting at all the same level of interaction with
Linkdin.
The way you do it is two ways.
Either you adapt the message to people or you just, uh,
publish the
same which I decided to do and actually acquired a little
very cool
service called PFN to just help you do that, share
everywhere at the
same time.
You have to be everywhere.
You have to identify your best fans.
It's not ant getting a million fans like MC Hammer.
It's about getting the first --
>>
[Laughing]
Loic: I mean, we all --
>>
[Laughing]
Loic: We all dream about that; right?
But it's -- at the beginning it's about -- I'm actually
quoting
Hammer.
He knows that for an hour ago he said that.
But you have to start with a hundred people, then 200 very
committed
fans, you have to focus on those.
I really advise you to read Seth Godin's book, "Tribes".
He quotes actually someone else saying a thousand fans can
get the
word out to millions and you really have to focus on the
small group.
When you do create focus on the very small social network
that you
could create for them like we did, we have these thousand
fans on
Seesmic.
It's a Ning social network called Team Seesmic where we
gather them
all and we give them exclusives, we can give them products
before
anyone else and I think they like it.
Love your users.
I did something very bad to our office managers two weeks
ago.
I said, who wants some stickers, and we have, like, 50,000
followers
on twitter and we received 500 e-mails in an hour of fans
who wanted
stickers of, you know, of a raccoon which is there on my
computer and
of course we sent every single -- so she loved me.
For about a week she was sending stickers and then we found
a company
that.
But now we have a Seesmic sticker on a snow board, you know,
people
tweet the picture so it's very good love around you.
And I'm almost done.
You have to be everywhere and on every platform.
And I'm talking about your brand, your company here.
Very tough.
You have to be on the web, you have to be on the iPhone,
now, too, you
have to have an Android app, you have to have a Nokia app to
reach the
2 million users that still Nokia has between Europe and Asia
and not
so much in fact U.S., you have to have a Blackberry app.
So it's a nightmare.
As a developer, it's horrible because these are all
difficult bases.
But that's our goal.
There are some companies that can help you do that but if
you have a
cool brand you should probably think about being everywhere.
And I'm almost done.
You need to use social networking internally if you want to
get
familiar with it.
Sales force is doing a whole thing with that.
You have to participate in all the cool events that all the
social
networking junkies like Scoble, go to, Southwest, you know,
Leaf, DLD,
web, tech50, and so on.
Go there and meet them even if you're not a geek brand.
You have to have real people in front of those brands
because it's
like it's not about Ford.
It's more ant who answers at Ford.
We want to have a human relationship.
And few little things.
Use video, very good as Robert knows, of course; be
proactive and
share as much as you can.
Think about we're gonna have coffee, what do we talk about,
or have
lunch, what do we talk about?
Don't think about what should be my next press release
because that's
going to be very boring.
If I, you know, have coffee with you and I only talk about
in terms
marketing, press release, it is going to be super boring.
I want to know about you and companies start to have a human
voice.
Last point: Passions.
It takes years.
It doesn't take days.
It take years.
It doesn't take months either.
Building trust around yourself helps as brands or around
your company
takes years.
It's a very long process but then it's extremely useful for
doing
good, for helping others, and if you focus on helping
others, even
though you're a profit-oriented business, it's probably a
good -- a
good rule.
So anyway, that was my 22-cents.
Thank you very much.
>>
[Applause]